here another tearjerker over here
actually it's currently national
volunteer week and national therapy
animal day is coming up on the 30th
so in honor southwest medical hospice
care is sharing their partnership with
pet partners
of las vegas check this out
teddy hello it's very very special to
bring
therapy animals into the hospice
experience
because it can provide things that no
other
no other avenue can one it's comforting
it's peaceful the secret is having a
calm animal we can have
her stroking him and petting him and
that's lowering her blood pressure and
steadying her heart rate
and giving you something fun to do
because don't forget joy
joy is very important in life it's joy
to have a pet
to visit me now i love animals
especially dogs and
i'm not able to have an
animal 24 7. so it's
nice that you come by and bring
a animal so i can enjoy it for a short
time
we are an accredited crisis team here in
las vegas so we have been doing quite a
lot through covid
but we always need new teams and
different types of people and
and their animals and it is a long
process for us you see the temperament
that we require
so it always starts with the natural
natural being of the animal
and then the human end of the leash has
to want to volunteer there's nothing
better
nothing more rewarding this is the best
way for me to spend my morning with you
american you know i did yeah as you
heard beverly say
we need more volunteers she'd love to
have a pet probably visit her every day
and we are very fortunate to have very
strong strategic partnerships here in
las vegas
the exquisite volunteer education and
training given from southwest medical
hospice partnered with the training we
do for the human and animal end
for therapy work has worked beautifully
together because they understand
how we are we understand what their
needs are and so we
are always looking for volunteers with
different species mostly dogs of course
but we do have nine different species we
register
yes i've been getting this visit
april 30th is national animal therapy
day
and we celebrate it every year we'll be
doing an event the night before with one
of our partners
and we want to promote the human animal
bond more than anything
we as what we call professional
volunteers do go out into the public
with our
well-trained well-mannered pets but
everybody can celebrate their own pet
because they all give us therapy in
their own ways but we do want people to
recognize that it
is a serious endeavor we are not
paid the same currency as in our jobs
perhaps
but we're paid in many other ways i'm
paid right now that my dog is falling
asleep he's so happy
this is enriching and this afternoon
i'll be somewhere else with another one
of my pets
so i think national therapy day is a day
to just bring awareness
that we are out there that it is
something very rewarding to do and if
you love being with your pet and you
want to give to others what's a better
combination than
do therapy work so sweet
beverly if you're watching hey girl miss
you for more information call
702-671-1111.com
we'll be right back